how does voter turn out in midterms
compared to presidential elections
traditionally midterm elections have
been years in which the voter turnout is
much lower than a presidential election
and particularly in recent history where
the american political scene has been
really dominated by the president we can
start that really with john f kennedy
when he became a celebrity president and
really everybody increasingly has just
sort of seen american political activity
uh originating and and swirling around a
president and so if they're interested
in the president well they turn out for
the presidential election but in the
off-year elections in the midterms well
the president's not really on the ballot
even if some people tend to see the
elections as a referendum on his
presidency so people turn out in less in
lower numbers we've also seen a trend
and it may be upturned in 2018 but a
trend where republican voters who tend
to be older are uh participate in the
voting and midterm elections more than
younger voters who tend to vote
democratic or voters of color who vote
for the democratic party as well it's
always been one of the challenges for
democrats to get their team to turn out
and vote in these midterm elections
you